on est aujourd'hui pour sortir un peu de
trappes parce que ce qu'on voit à
trappes on est en train de le voir
partout en france et il ya des centaines
et des centaines de quartiers
aujourd'hui où les femmes ne peuvent
plus circuler sans être importuné ou des
femmes portent le voile parce que porter
le voile c'est l'assurance d'être d'être
tranquille et moi je suis favori dernier
titre qui porte le wat sont très
religieux du voile dans l'espace public
que je considère que ce n'est rien les
jeunes dames là bas qu'il était juste
que je conseille j'ai plus loin qu eric
zemmour je considère que le voile est un
marqueur n'ont pu seulement maintenant
religieux un marqueur politique qui
marque une différence entre les hommes
et les femmes et je suis désolé de dire
cela mais je pense que ces marqueurs
religieux qui sont des marqueurs
rigoriste convoi dans des pays musulmans
la france n'est pas l'arabie saoudite la
france ce n'est pas l'iran et quand on
vient en france on vit comme un français
donc moi je pense qu'on peut
parfaitement être issu lignes anciennes
de sentir pleinement de
conditionnalité justice qui
est sinon l'espace jordan or ces
manifestations on est entraîneur et je
vous le dit d'ailleurs est-ce que vous
condamnez le fait que dans certains bas
on ne puissent plus avoir de femmes
aujourd'hui à laisser leur et de rentrer
mais est-ce que les servants écueil et
que je 4 coiffure mixte sur 13 balayé
des enseignants s'élèvent
à répondre à lire et vous disiez zéro
maintenant vous dites qu'il n'a
finalement 4 dont ça va on progresse
c'est vous qui l'avez moi je suis pas
vous êtes très bien coiffée j'aimerais
merci pour les coiffeurs notera place
vous savez vos propos caricaturaux
outrancier et c'est les français qui
vivent au quotidien sur ces territoires
ne les supporte plus parce que ça ne
l'est pas aucune réalité la réalité
l'est déjà assez difficile à vivre des
difficultés à briller à la mélisse
djihadisme etc ça existe et ses délires
c'est douloureux comme ça et j'ai deux
ans à nicher questionnement par les
difficultés pour les régler les gens
comme vous qui viennent agiter la haine
pour le coup vous ne servez que de
carburant à ceux qui veulent essayer de
ap et d'europe et de radicaliser une
partie de la jeunesse de l'autralie
rabais